[Music]
you enjoyed a few parts of one and some
parts of the other but went to popcorn
movies are so aggressively okay there's
only enough to say about them to make
one honest trailer are you being serious
Pacific Rim uprising and Tomb Raider
double feature don't get mad we double
these up you know you were to see by
Panther instead anyway prepare for two
perfectly fine moderately entertaining
films that exist for the least exciting
reasons Time Warner's legal department
acquired an established IP from
Paramount and Comcast accountants notice
one of their movies over performed in
China instead of you know someone had a
new story to tell or something to say
about the world or yeah I know I sound
like my grandpa I'll just be in the shed
Suda with two V's working their butts
off to make these franchises a thing as
they both battle severe daddy issues and
Japanese MacGuffins in two films that
start with fun opening sequences descent
into by-the-numbers action and end with
a tease for a sequel that'll probably
never come to them next time we're gonna
confident I'll take two I'm good with
one thanks now that Oscar winner
Guillermo del Toro Ron Perlman and
Charlie Hunnam are gone we're left with
Pacific Finn a reluctant mentor to the
next generation very reluctant shut up
shut up I can't do that if you jump in
your gums you need to meet and become
friends
what record shut up when he sent secret
information from a dead family member
he'll team up with an assortment of
heroic Chinese people to save the world
and super impractical robot battles that
are so insanely destructive there won't
be much of a world left to live in
either way
now that Angelina Jolie Jon Voight and
Jorah Mormont's go on we're left with
Laura Croft fit and orphan who gets in
over her head way over her head when she
said secret information from a dead
family member or she'll team up with an
assortment of heroic Chinese people but
you find one guy went on life on high
then save the world and a super
impractical tomb that's so generic
you'll wish they left her as Laura Croft
GrubHub delivery biker you know anyone
can read a tomb hitting Chipotle from
midtown to the Bronx in 20 minutes or
less now that is exciting but no to
blockbusters are exactly alike
God is the female objectification from
the first Tomb Raider while Pacific Rim
picks up the slack eyes front and cos
and one as a villain too drab to be
interesting while the other as a villain
too silly to be believed I'm ending the
world where uprising would have been
better if it was more grounded in
reality
while Tomb Raider would have been better
with a little more fun or three big
dinosaurs or something so the next time
all the new releases are checked out of
red box or you accidentally leave FX on
on a Sunday afternoon you can't go wrong
settling on the movie based on the video
game that was trying to look like a
movie or the movie trying as hard as it
possibly can to look like the video game
either way you're gonna have an okay
time these days ok will do just fine
starring through the Shoom
his third by the rules' military
character in 6 movies crash band across
a waste of a perfectly good
Rinku all voice no principles Vic daddy
Master Chief let's tiny Stark and burn
gorman that sounds like a parody name
but nope his name is actually burn
gorman Pacific trim up Rimmer we're not
the only ones who cross Tomb Raider with
another movie the poster mixed it with
Jurassic Park Alan
they're alive just like me there is
cheese and mypads
get it out I am your wife I'm the
greatest good you are ever gonna get
lost of ahista by bay turn on your voice
chat